And we are very excited to host here
today at all for authors of the book.
Second Shift,
the inside story of the keep g m movement.
So a few words about the book.
First before I introduce
you to the authors who are
very kindly joined us today,
add to take us through the book and
to take your questions and answers the
second half of the session.
So the book details,
the complexities of an automotive industry
rapidly transforming due to external
economic and market forces at community
reliant upon a local manufacturing
facility schedules to be added to
a long list of plant shutdowns,
a variety of factions and personalities
at odds with the city of Lansing and
[inaudible] committed to persuading
GM to reverse course on its decision.
So a really,
really great topic for us to discuss
today and we are delighted that the four
authors of the book at can join us.
Um,
so I'm going to introduce you
now to each of them. Um, David.
Hello David. Um, he was
the mayor of Lansing. Uh,
you're in Michigan from a 1994 to 2003
and you'll hear a lot more about David's
role. And as we go through the
presentation, a retired person, ray,
a former president and CEO of [inaudible],
a Michigan based architectural and an
engineering firm working closely with Mary
David Hollister on the keep GM campaigns
for the last ingredient Michigan
community and raise served as the senior
strategic and marketing advisor to
marry David Hollister during
his time at David close,
correctly pronounced yes,
professor McConnell endowed chair and
the chair person of the Department of
Supply chain management in the Eli Broad
College of business at Michigan State
University. And then Thomas Cole, um,
professor of Byington and endowed a
chair and director of the International
Business Center in the Eli Broad
College of business at Michigan State
University also.
And then finally Terry on the end here.
I'm executive producer of a company
called message maker who prepared the
documentary on the, on this great
story. So without further ado,
I'm going to hand you over to Thomas.
You're going to lead us through the
details of the book and then we'll be back
in 30 minutes or so to take your
questions and answers. Thank you.
[inaudible].
All right. We're going to do a little
bit of the David clothes in particular,
but also myself, we're very big
into supply chain management.
The Michigan State University is known
for that. We're going to try to do some,
uh, play with some logistical
challenges at the weave together.
This story if you will for you.
We're going to try to do it pretty
rapidly including a couple of clips,
but the logistics comes in because I'm
going to hand the mic back and forth to
the coauthor says well on
different segment topics.
So hopefully that becomes engaging and
hopefully we stopped talking soon enough
so that you guys can engage us with
questions as well. So second shift,
you see the book cover,
uh,
there's a documentary film that Terry
Terry and his team at message makers
should put together as well.
There's a 55 minute documentary.
It's been shown on PBS.
Detroit will be shown a nationwide,
we think this fall or,
or soon thereafter.
So there's a little bit of a branding
package there to talk about this
particular story. So Mayor
Hollister came into office in 1994,
if I remember it correctly,
and this story started in 1996 and then
we take it from there actually up until
last month, if you will. Uh, because
the GM and part of the world,
this is very fascinating. Uh, so
book cover to go back to that,
it's just a little bit of the scenery
and Lansing, we don't play it off march,
but it's the senior and the landscape a
little bit, uh, uh, city line in Lansing.
So the story goes back to something
to the tune of their 78 general motors
assembly plants worldwide.
Right now they're 18 as assembly plants
in the United States. And an interesting,
we have two of them in Lansing and
we've had a car manufacturer and their,
since technically 1897
with the old motor works,
really started production
in 1901. But then, uh,
we kind of reopened that would rate tag
nigger Chans help and others in 2001,
the old plant that became kind of a newer
plant and newest at the time and then
Delta Assembly became the second
one that opening Lansing in 2006.
So it's been going on forever and ever.
So the keep GM campaign had lots of
obviously with the mayor and others,
lots of political connotations to it
that did the community one GMA Lansing or
it didn't matter that we lost uh, uh,
those number of employees or other things.
And the storyline is pretty
powerful. Uh, and I don't know,
we can look at a lot of different numbers,
but the numbers we like looking at are
there roughly 7,000 GM employees at the
two plans a little bit shorter that,
that the two plants in Lansing,
there's a 10 to one multiplier effect,
meaning that for every one General
Motors employee in Lansing,
there 20,000 more employees in the Tri
County area around where we are that
serve Lansing. And there are another
50,000 employees and other companies.
So there's 70,000 people at different
companies that support the two plants in
Lansing. So you've got 70,000
of them, 7,000 of GM employees,
and then it goes uh,
almost crazy from their GM in Lansing
has 2,700 tier one suppliers and over
50,000 tier two suppliers gets a little
bit technical and the terminology,
but there's a lot of infrastructure that
depend on this particular set up that
may or Hollister was able
to frankly save for Lansing.
And obviously we have other communities
in Michigan that we can talk about if we
can talk about what it meant, not tab
these plants there. So lots of numbers,
lots of fun stories and
hopefully we can get into it.
So the mayor was elected in 1993,
came into office on January 1st
that's a weird date, the start mayor,
but January 1st of 1994 and two years
after he got this knock on the door and
he'll explain that a little bit.
We're going to let them dwell on it after
I sort of set up the stage for where
we're going with a storyline. A, but
that's his lovely wife Chris as well.
And they're happy and Smiley on the
little bit in order to years later,
we're just going to trash our commune
if basically that was the knock on the
door he got done and gee,
I'm not only did they say
that they were going to leave,
there were some good stuff there too.
And we'll get into that too. But, uh,
not only where they're going to leave,
the mayor wasn't allowed to
tell anybody publicly anywhere.
That was kind of what GM walked into
his office with literally. All right,
so you sitting here contemplating
what happens and the add,
Donovan is the knock on the door.
We actually talk about and put
it in quotes are as well. Uh,
and that happened very early.
Now Mayor Hollister has been
in the legislature for 20
some years and worked in
politics for a lot of, a lot
of years, even after it was
may or you worked in, uh,
back in, uh, Governor Granholm
regime, if you will in Michigan.
But this is a pretty big task to take on,
uh,
when you have lots of different parties.
40 through the tune of 40 signed on
to actually partner with the mayor.
In this particular case, we have
a couple of clips. This is a clip,
Terry Terry's team up.
Message makers were the producers of
the documentary and this is the trailer
that they produced as well.
And it sort of captures all of the
things that I said then sets us up and
scoping out where we're going with this.
So let's take a little bit of a look.
This is always the general motors towel.
Always an Oldsmobile town,
got elected in [inaudible] 93 I get
a knock on my door one day from vice
president. General Motors said, we got
some good news and I got some bad news.
We're going to be launching this
100 year birthday of my pill.
But when this mine of product and we
don't have any new product from Lansing,
all of a sudden thousands of manufacturing
jobs were at risk. Where do you start?
There were people who said,
you know,
we're not willing to give everything
to cheat in order to keep them.
And they said publicly, well,
if GM leaves us oil production,
it's no big deal.
We'll become a wine drinking community
like Ann Arbor instead of a beer drinking
can. Like, we've always been, well
you know what, if nobody has a job,
there's nobody there to buy the
wine and cheese manufacturing,
they say supports between seven
and 10 jobs within the community.
So it means everything to the city.
The mayor's approach to it was,
we need to take this public, not to
fight with Jim, but fight for champ
right in the heart of our city. And I
commit to doing everything in my power.
How do you get two new plants built
when you have plants being closed around
America
in this time span, they literally
close dozens and dozens of plants.
And the key part of the story is that
when the GM at that particular time at
announce the closure, they had never
actually gone back on that decision.
So it was a fantastic upheld
battle that these guys face.
So back to the team,
just to define those a little bit.
So Ray obviously mayor
Hollister was to lead them,
trying to figure out a team to keep
GM. He uh, enlisted immediately,
right tab your son a boy.
That's an architectural thing but frankly
to speak engineering with GM because
they didn't want to be
spoken to in marketing terms.
They want it to be spoken
to an engineering terms.
So that was part of the
strategy I guess as well. Uh,
Terry Terry and his team,
Tom Leitz is a picture here as well.
They're the producers. Again, all of
the while we called the PBS documentary,
but documentary that was shown on PBS,
at least in Detroit and it
looks like beyond that as well.
And then the two of us are
David close again on my left.
Your right and myself are endowed,
chaired professors at Michigan state too.
I've been entrenched in the auto community
and supply chain management and all
of these different things for
years and years and years. In fact,
David got his phd from Michigan State,
so really years and years and years.
So we're very much entrenched and
motivated to not only tell this story,
but also capture the fact that general
motors not only provides a manufacturing
platform for cars or provider
manufacturing platform for
a lot of different know
high tech and other things
as well for our community.
And it goes back to the logo. Lansing
works keep Gm. And the idea was that, uh,
even to this day in January this year,
uh,
I'll leave it nameless because we
don't want to compete against other
communities per se. But, uh, this year,
Lansing Economic Club had a senior
VP on from GM and he came in and,
and frankly set again at the GM workforce,
just the best we have and the GM umbrella,
you know,
that 78 plans later around the world,
we can start arguing on ranking that.
But nevertheless, coming in to
tell 500 people at the GM Lansing,
a workforce just fantastically highly
qualified that this play an off the
Lansing works. The Lansing
works. It's what the mayor
struck in the late nineties,
as this say in just that, and
it still resonates a, okay.
So we have the, before we're going to
shoot it out to the three coauthor share.
We have one animated,
the two minute clip that presents the
overview of not only the book book itself
for sure, but the six dimensional
sort of framework for what uh,
Lansing used in a codafide version.
So these guys went through it and
David close and I n together with Terry
Terry's team,
sort of codify what the solution
actually became that can be used by other
communities around the world,
certainly around the country.
We know Rio de Janeiro for example,
is looking at the,
using something like this right now
for complex problem they're having.
And that's kind of
fascinating and out of itself.
The book just came out
a couple of weeks ago,
so let's take a take a look at the
animated clip and that captures, uh,
the storyline of the book.
When car making giant General Motors
decided to close its plant in Lansing,
Michigan. In 1996, one person,
the city's newly elected
mayor stood up and said, no.
Initially it was the cry
of a man in the wilderness.
Not once in a century long history had
GM reversed a decision to close a plant,
but mayor David Hollister quietly went
to work building the lensing works,
keep GM movement and succeeded
in defying all the odds.
Hollister's collaborative
problem solving approach.
The second shift model succeeded in
bringing together state and regional
politicians, economic
developers, private sector firms,
labor unions,
educators and residents of the region.
The second shift model is
a dynamic collaborative
management model that saved a
u s manufacturing city.
Hollister's coalition implemented a
strategic six dimensional framework to
achieve the seemingly
impossible identifying name,
the challenge and its impact.
Partnering,
develop meaningful relationships,
building construct your
strategy as you go. Solving,
engage in constant problem solving,
celebrating mark successful
milestones and persevering,
adapt and endure. It is powerful,
persuasive and well organized.
The Lansing works.
Keep GM movement was a victory of people
over bureaucracy of a can do attitude
over cynicism.
It's proof positive that when the public
and private sectors work together as
equal partners,
both sides come away.
Winners one of the Great
Business Sagas of modern times.
Second Shift provides a proven practical
designed for problem solving that
anyone can apply in any business
or community, large or small.
So it's very easy to go back in the,
you know,
330,000 words or a 30 70 interviews or
807 pages of interview notes if you will,
to come up with that six
dimensional framework.
If your professor clothes and myself,
it's a little bit tougher
if you're retired,
the Sean and David Hollister in 1996 to
2001 to actually figure out how to get
all these players on board and we have
some historical documents and the book
for example,
one is a document that we're at 40
different at both senators from Michigan,
lots of congressmen and on and on and on.
A character's signed on to work together.
There were so many different
competing interests. The
new Delta towns, your plans,
for example,
it's a competing township technically,
but became a collaborator in
this process and and so on.
So the collaboration is pretty unique
and we're hoping that other communities
can learn from that at least as a starting
framework for where to go with it.
And that's what they are.
Again.
So we've got the identify and we've got
partnering, we've got buildings solving,
celebrating, persevering, eh,
there's eight chapters in the book,
you one chapter for each of those,
plus the introduction chapter that sets
the context to where we are as well as a
little bit of all the different political
and other issues that have to be
talked about it. Then figure out,
frankly solved. And then the shop there,
eighth comes back to managerially talk
about perhaps how to implement it and
where to go with it.
In the process.
We have quotes from senator
this precedent that x, Y,
and z throughout the book and everywhere
weaving them together in a nice
storyline,
including 37 I believe,
different challenges as well
as the six dimensions here.
Filter down to 33 different,
I'm gonna call them variables
right now since I'm an academic.
But these guys will dwell
on them here in a minute.
So let's look at those a little
bit in the context of second shift.
And I wasn't going to do this, but, uh,
we'll call a mayor Hollister right away
on second shift because I think I've
been talking about this. Why did they
call the book Second Shift Mayor?
We are wanting to take the opportunity to,
when we did the launch of the Alero,
which was a part of the 100
year celebration of the phone,
involves going to bill and send a signal
to General Motors in Detroit that we
were so confident in our
workforce that it was our, our,
our strongest asset that we
would launch the project.
Uh, on the second shift,
traditionally new, uh,
shifts or new products are done in
the first shift where I have all the
engineers and the managers and the
executives and the senior UAW leadership.
So the old foxes of the unions,
uh, and my dad included, it,
worked there 35 years. So
Jim's UPC code, the, uh, uh,
the, uh, manager of the
plant and our Baker,
the local UAW guy came to me and said,
we want to send a signal.
We're going to put it all on the table,
we're going to sec a,
launch it on the second shift and get
their attention. So that's what we did.
Now we had to identify the problem because
General Motors to just inform me that
they're going to be having this
wonderful a week long celebration.
Thousands of people coming, thousands
of cars. It's going to be great.
And we're going to launch this alarm
on Lansing. This is all good news.
But the bad news is when that production
is over that we have no product,
the General Motors, it's not
going to in the region. And uh,
that that's kind of a sock in the stomach.
And he also said,
you can't tell anybody. So this
is a private information, uh,
uh, you can, uh, decide which can
do. And I'm a newly elected mayor,
this is not great news. I can figure
out how maybe I can get out of town, uh,
and run for something else
or, you know, forget this,
give it to the chamber to figure out.
But we decided to partner with a gym sock,
couldn't the UAW and uh,
and uh, use that launch, uh,
to, to do it. Uh, we had two, two, two,
two tasks as we defined the problem.
I mean this is falls under the
category of identifying the problem.
I was just going to move on to
identifying which is your topic.
May or so we will keep the mayor
going on in identifying the problem.
Tell us about that.
Well we're not,
he came there at General Motors was the
number one company in the fortune 500 my
dad worked for General
Motors for 35 years.
My father in law worked
with the same 30 plus years.
We took General Motors for granted.
We thought that you've
got the state government,
you've got Michigan State University
and you've got GM and that's the three
pillars and that provided a middle class
income and it's going to go on forever.
Little did we realize that below the
surface that allow general motors was a
planning, the launch, the a, the
campaign on the 100th birthday,
they were retrenching and
between 1990 and 2005,
they actually closed 40 plants.
And once they announced the closing,
they never reverse themselves.
So we were looking at the reality,
we were being told we're going to close
your plants after 2005 a these are the
oldest plants. Uh, they
were 100 years old. Uh,
some of the buildings I had wood floors,
so it was a fire hazard.
And so you had the legacy costs and,
and,
and, and you had a number of
other, um, factors going on.
We had to educate General Motors about
why they needed to stay and we had to
reeducate them about the
value of our workforce.
And we had to get our own act together.
When I talked to Donovan and he talked
to Donald and was the GM vice president,
uh, he wanted to know who he would
be working with in the region,
how many different taxing units
were there in the Tri County area.
And it turned out that though,
I didn't know at the time there were 130
taxing units and General Motors wanted
to deal with just one with one.
So we had to create an unified regional,
uh,
problem solving a strategy
that could reverse a decision,
has never been reversed by General
Motors and do that knowing that, uh, the,
the economy was pretty shaky and a
of foreign competition was coming in.
They were losing market share and we
were going to have to change all that
territory.
So just concluding your about the
why it was called second shift.
The Alero was launched on the second
shift and it was the most successful new
product launch and GMS entire history.
When Jim has told us that and
the interview we just said,
that's gotta be the title. And
uh, and the story of course,
just that nobody works on the second and
third shift except torics those, darn,
it's a necessity to work shift I guess.
But that's a fantastic story to tell them
that the engineers and everybody else
was home sleeping and we still trust
to this community to take care of that
particular, uh, launch, which
became incredibly successful.
Developing meaning real
meaningful relationships.
It's the next story and the sixth
dimensional framework that we also called
partnering. It's a little hard
to see on the yellow one there,
but developing meaningful partnerships.
And I already alluded to this and we're
going to invoke ray tab. You're Sean,
because we had the 40,
incredibly high lofty community members,
uh, sign on to doing this stuff where I'm
not sure all 40 of them compete against
each other before they
signed this document.
But it seemingly could have
been that way the way you,
our friends tell the story.
So there was a lot of competition and
they came through the same table at this
particular point in time,
right?
The mayor's vision for this campaign was
to bring people together and make it a
collaborative effort.
Now when you have competing townships,
who would love to have the any new
product line, any new plant, uh,
they're all looking out for their own
self interest as they should be because
they're representing their constituents
while the mayor was representing the
region.
And that's the way he wanted to come
across is that this was a regional effort.
So trying to get those 40 communities
to get on board, plus the chamber,
plus the city council, people were
telling him, you're wasting your time.
GM has never changed their mind
about doing something like this.
When they're going to close the plant,
they're going to close the plant.
So why are you wasting your time wasting
the city's money, wasting your energy,
your efforts, you can put your
time into something better.
But the mayor had a vision.
He wanted this to be a world
class city and the anchor,
one of the anchors to that
would be general motors,
keeping them and trying to
convince them to stay. So,
in doing so, he brought on all these
different elements of the community,
neighborhood people,
uh, the Union folks, uh,
just about everyone that you can
think of somehow got on board.
We started and launched the Blue Ribbon
Committee and we had 28 people there
that were a part of the committee
at the time. We eventually had, uh,
50 people on that committee and,
but that was too large.
You couldn't make decisions. The
discussions became like a free for all.
And uh, so we had to create what
we call the quick response team.
That was a team of about six folks who
met weekly to try to make decisions on
what was going to be said to the public,
how much going to be said to the public,
where were we at in the status,
what was her next challenge? Uh,
Thomas alluded that there were over 35
major challenges and I'm talking about
major challenges,
getting the edge legislature to
change the laws to enable, uh,
a tax abatements and incentives to be
used to retain a plant as opposed to
trying to retract new jobs. Uh,
getting the chamber on board,
they were convinced they were going to
lead this effort that took weeks to get
resolved and getting the
townships on onboard.
They really didn't want to do this,
but they felt like they had to because
they needed to keep an eye on Dave.
They knew they didn't want him doing
something that he shouldn't be doing.
So these people all got on
board and the city console,
he actually had to change the console,
get three new people on board
because there were three negatives.
Then you heard the story about we become
like Ann Arbor wine drinking instead of
beer drinking and bowling town.
Eh, depends on the, well Jason
says otherwise, but you know,
at any rate, partnering became
a big part of this. And uh,
so the mayor asked me if I would do
this and when I, when he first asked me,
because we had a successful partnership
before that in building the Baseball
Stadium Downtown Lansing. So when he asked
me, Ray, can you do this? I said, sure,
absolutely. We were going back from
Toledo, so we had a two hour bus drive.
And I'm thinking all the way back
to last week. What did I just do?
I don't have a clue as to how to do this.
But then we put,
I put together a strategic plan for
this and created all these different
partnerships and all of these
subcommittees and uh, figure it out.
If everybody did their job,
we might have a shot. So
we're going to build plants
in about five or six slides.
We're going to build a couple of plants.
Uh, that's a fantastic undertaking,
an achievement to get 40 of those sets.
I know it's impossible to see,
but if you look in the book,
you're going to see all of those
different titles and characters that I
described,
if we construct your strategy as you go.
So the last thing on the planet,
anybody should do is construct
your strategy as you go.
You usually want to plan of some
kind and unfollow a roadmap.
But we're frankly at Google and the
first place I can think of where you
construct your strategy as you go.
It's probably a company like this.
So at least one company on the planet,
they may resonate.
What the mayor Hollister and
rates had the son dead. Eh,
that's not the norm that the General
Motors would fall for example,
but that's the norm that had to be
followed. In this particular case.
On the left hand side there of the slide,
you see a bunch of those
variables if you will,
to under sub dimensions of these things.
We're not going to go into those,
but they are described and talked about
in the book and how they were used to
construct your strategy as you go.
I'm going to invoke David
close on that particular topic.
Thank you, Thomas. It was,
it was not a situation where you could
develop a strategy and a and then
executed.
It was far too dynamic than that.
As you see some of the key points on
on the list that Thomas said on the
previous slide, there's someone, uh,
you, you have a dynamic environment of a,
what's the auto industry looked like?
It was clear the auto
industry was changing from a
situation where you had the
people that came out of a high school
and the vocab thing to a very high tech
development process.
Changing workforce. Uh,
it was clear in this case, we have a
very big challenge in communicating,
uh, to the environment you had is,
is Dave Hollister talked about, uh,
the challenge of, uh, the internal
group that you shared information with.
You have the community who wasn't
quite sure of what's going on here. Uh,
you have general motors who is saying,
we made a decision and
we're going to move on.
And then you have local people
from General Motors who,
who know that the quality of the
Lansing workforce. And so it was,
is keeping those four things, those four
balls in the air throughout the process.
And that, that became a lot of the
challenges as we read through the, uh, um,
the manuscripts and the interviews.
It's like looking at those
things and balancing them and,
and doing the trade offs and, uh,
just having a strategy in place and,
and, and, and keeping that going,
uh, was the key part. And that's,
that's one of the key lessons. I think
one other point I want wanted to make,
and we're Dave Hollister
and I first started working
together, is if you look at,
uh, many communities trying to
retain manufacturing environment,
which is something that
I've worked on a lot, it's,
there's historically a lot of uh,
conflict as is ray talked about and
how do I get them to realize that for a
business point of view, a city's boundary
or counties boundary is irrelevant.
It's how do I put together a
region and get the workforce to,
to make it work together. And that's
not, that's not just a Lansing problem,
although I think this story
shows that we've a cow, uh,
did a lot to accomplish it,
but it's other regions too,
including southeast Michigan.
Okay.
The dynamic nature of problem
solving is played up and,
and will be called engage in constant
problem solving as well. I mean,
think about where you guys are right now.
Self driving cars,
just a totally different phenomenon from
late nineties or 50 years ago or 1897
if you want to go really far back.
And that's not the same mindset.
Same strategy,
same person,
same toolkit to actually
get into that arena.
Even though seemingly for the average
customer, it seems like it's a car,
but it's a total different dynamic. And
I think these guys ran into that as well.
Uh, engage in problems in constant
problem solving. We're going to recycle.
We're going to go back to a mayor
Hollister to talk about engaging constant
problem solving.
Well, I was confronted with this
knowledge. The gentleman was leaving,
uh, the Chamber of Commerce, uh,
wanted to continue to take the lead
on a retention that was one of their
traditional roles. I didn't feel that
was going to be adequate. Uh, and,
and I had to think about any community
could offer a tax break. I mean,
any, all communities, all states
have some kind of tax package.
We wanted to go beyond that and
create something very unique.
So we created a single entry single exit,
one stop shopping and
problem solving center.
So we said to the community
and to General Motors,
if you have any problem that
you want solved, you bring
it to the mayor's office.
That's the one,
one stop single entry.
And that if the mirror is office isn't,
uh,
we identifying or justifying the,
the data,
then it's just a rumor.
I mean it's Kinda become
directly from the mayor's office.
So you've got a single entry single exit,
one stop.
And we asked General Motors to give
us 30 days and any problem they wanted
solved any problem and we would tackle
it and we would come up with a solution.
We had a problem of odor
on the, uh, on the, uh,
west side of town and we
engaged the community to,
to solve that. We got the health
department involved, got neighbors,
Neighborhood Association involved, the
environmental groups who are out there,
uh, you know, opposing us initially, uh,
saying that General Motors shouldn't
be getting more capacity to build in
Lansing because of the air quality
was not adequate. And, and so,
uh, we had to figure out that strategy.
Uh, we got the schools involved.
Um, we put an, uh, an air monitoring, uh,
m and a weather monitoring,
uh,
equipment at the local high
school football stadium.
And so they could get the every day
they were getting data on air speed and
temperature and humidity
and all that stuff.
And I've got the schools involved
in the students involved.
And then we got the engineers at General
Motors to start tutoring in the schools.
So we had to try to be very comprehensive
in our, and our strategy. Uh,
General Motors a as we won the,
uh,
the designation of the most
successful launch ever, uh, uh, uh,
uh,
Mark A.
Hogan indicated that he would
consider Lansing for the plant.
We were originally told her you
wouldn't have any chance at all,
but because we were so successful in his
problem solving that he gave us a shot
at it. Uh, and so we
had to, we had to, uh,
deliver on that promise, but it
was, uh, we brought to the table,
the township officials, the city
officials, the state officials,
the governor and I were at odds
with each other. The legislature,
I was a liberal democrat.
He was a conservative Republican.
We fought like cats and dogs.
Uh,
but when we were both executives
trying to save this industry,
we decided to, to work together. So
we put together a strategy and we, uh,
delivered on it and we solved
virtually every problem.
And one of the key ones was rate,
looked at the internet,
figured out how to build a plant
and the downtown Lansing site,
uh, and do it without, uh,
disrupting the production and without
taking a greenfield and turn it into a,
uh,
a plant.
Actually, let's start it over to ray
to tell the plant stores a little bit.
Well, that plant story's kind of
interesting because when Marc Hogan,
the vice president for General Motors
said he was considering building a plant.
They were building Cadillacs in Eisenach,
Germany and they wanted
to stop that production,
bring the Cadillacs back to the
United States. They didn't say where,
but they didn't say or when, but they
were going to build a plant somewhere.
Well to really try to figure out what
they wanted to do and why they want it to
do it.
They had to build a business case here
to that says it would be cost effective
to build it wherever they're going
to build it. Well fortunately for me,
I was led to a set of plans that came
from the plant manager at the time Jim's
up,
cause he pointed me to a,
a set of photocopies of a
plant that was built in Brazil.
It had a code name blue McCall.
This was very confidential information.
He told me,
you can't share this with anybody.
You can't tell anybody where you got it
from. I said, okay, can I tell the mayor?
He goes, okay, there's three of us.
And so I shared it with the mayor,
but it took me a week to figure out would
that plant fit or not because it was
in metric and it was virtually
indiscernible as to what was on that.
So I had to create a new scale.
It was a scale of like one
inch equals 167 meters.
Something weird. You know, most
scales are not like that. Well,
I had to figure that out and figured
it out that this plant was built on 70
acres.
There was 180 at the existing plant site,
about half of which could be torn down.
And the buildings that were on there
could be torn down. They were vacant,
there were storage areas. So I said to
Jim, if you tear those buildings down,
this plant will fit there.
So Mark Hogan happened to be the vice
president who oversaw the project in
Brazil. And so when I showed
him this plan and said,
we can put this footprint on that plant
site, he said, where did you get that?
I said,
research.
And so we offered to take it back to
Detroit with him and he said that wasn't
necessary. He would take it himself.
And several months later he said,
we're going to build that plant.
So we,
we went through this celebrate [inaudible]
thing here of intermediate steps.
Obviously this is a long process.
So part of the model includes
celebrating as well as we go along.
And then the last one is persevering.
And that should go for obvious reason,
but if you don't celebrate till the end,
they're like,
we oftentimes do when
this particular process,
you don't get the community behind you
or these 40 different people signing on
and the organizations they represented.
So the celebration became an intermediate
as well as a final step in the process
and clearly getting a 70
acre plant where they may,
I wanted a couple of hundred acres or
really want to 300 acres and on and on.
And we're going to talk more
about acreage here on the,
on the last final slide I think.
So moving on to persevering and that's
adapt and endure in this particular
context. And I'm going to invoke a
professor close again on that topic.
Again,
this is the whole process is a very
dynamic environment and we had to adapt as
the, the educational structure change,
the workforce structure changed. Uh,
and even the, uh, the supply chain
structure changed. We had to bring in, uh,
suppliers and uh,
um,
get them involved in the process as we
came to the step of a second plant. Uh,
other issues came in in terms of
integrating that. So, uh, the,
the overall process, the
realization I think is that, um,
it's not, you just create a plant
and it's going to last a long time.
The plant is changing day to day.
And we had to switch that reality
both for both for General Motors and,
and of course they realize that.
But the community I don't think did,
and some of the lessons that that came
out of the interviews where what we have
to do with the community
to make it realize that.
And I think a Dr. Simon had miss you
made a very good quote on the back of the
book where she said,
we have to not take for granted what
we've had here in the past and be able to
adapt for it. And, and that's really one
of the big lessons that came out of it
and not the gloss over celebration too
much. Jason, of course, invited us here,
which is kind of cool.
And I think this was about two years
after Jason Played Basketball for Tamia.
So at Michigan State,
uh,
we're guessing it was mayor
was about 1998 season,
give or take that he dedicated to the
whole team and their season was dedicated
to the keep general motors in
the community as a campaign,
which is pretty cool.
So a couple of years after that again,
but he missed the dedication
to General Motors Jason did,
but he certainly won a
national championship that
may have been a better deal of
the, of the two. For us it was keeping
GM and winning national championships.
We want all of the above two
plants were built in a process.
Ultimately the outcome of
the storyline and stuff,
there's a 2001 plan to build
at the Grand River Assembly,
the 70 acres dot.
Right tag or Sean was talking about where
there were 180 or so acres available.
That's a hundred year old.
The on top of each other type plan with
nice drawings from Brazil. I mean the,
the storyline there is pretty deep and
interesting if you dig into the book as
well.
And then Delta township a
in 2006 that plant open.
So the Delta township supervisor, a mayor,
I'm not sure exactly the title there,
but anyway,
the leader of Delta township signed on
almost immediately when mayor Hollister
said, can you help out Lansing and
support our costs? And sure enough,
five years later,
which is really short time period,
they get their own gigantic plant.
The Delta Township plan producers
a little over 1100 cars a day.
Right now the Grand River assembler
produces about 700 and there were about
6,500 to be exact employees in town.
Um,
and I guess the UAW leadership loves
to tell the story about the last year
they've hired a thousand new workers and
all of them actually became members of
the union. So that's a storyline that
the, those guys like telling as well.
And our story, if according to Mayor
Hollister, uh, may not stop there,
this is the second,
the last slide.
So that's why we want to poke
on the community a little bit.
So as recently as June of this
year, uh, mayor Hollister,
when our record and saying that,
you know,
in General Motors owns 1100 acres
of farm land next to Delta Township,
that plant,
they only need anywhere from 70 to 300
acres depending on what size plant they
want to build. So they can blend,
build a lot more plants there.
And I guess the quote on this one is
CMA or gms and then the farming Bisnar
business Holister sheds.
So 1100 acres later,
I guess there's hope in the community
that that means something for the future
as well. And I know you guys are
getting a fantastic deal if you want to,
if you go at us, a regular customer
on Amazon or what have you,
it's a 30 buck deal,
but you guys get it to a 15 and they
sell as it looks at two you may get a
reimbursed as well.
So it's a pretty cheap deal in the
sense of having her on your bookshelf or
storyline. If I'd known Jason
was on the team back then,
I would have dug up a Tommy.
So the signature in the
process as well, but Tommy's,
it's again one of the testimonials on the
back page of or back cover rather have
the book plus a few of the characters
like senators and other show.
Thank you for indulging us if we will
take Q and a as you see fit from any of
the five of us including territory
of course was instrumental in this,
a message makers team to put this into
a documentary and so that's in in some
way the surface level
of the business model.
Let's nice 55 minutes to look at and
this is the more codafide version of the
six dimensional framework that we're
hoping other communities can learn
something form at least as a starting
point to solve similar problems and a
complex format.
Thanks everyone.
[inaudible]
yeah,
GM has
never before birth
you swallow hard,
you put on a good face.
He,
you begin gathering as much
information as you can to
formulate a strategy and then you
articulate a plan and engage partners and
begin the process of building trust.
Because without trust,
it's not going to work.
And this is going to be difficult
because you've got a fragmented region,
three counties,
and they're all competitors and there's
no history of collaboration. Uh,
so it was going to be important that we,
we incrementally bring people along.
And I made a commitment very
early to the regional leaders.
It must be a win win situation.
And this is critical to the other
communities that are facing us.
You bring your competitors to the table.
So we invited the township leadership
to the table. We invited the chamber,
the chamber in the law and the campaign,
when I ran from air,
it didn't even give me an interview.
I mean,
they endorsed my opponent without even
giving me an interview because I'd been
such a Liberal Democrat for 20 years.
So I had an,
I invited them to participate.
I asked the chairman of the chamber to
be the public face of the Blue Ribbon
Committee. So you're bringing
the diverse people together,
you do a transparent process,
you commit to win, win,
and then you begin problem solving.
Then part of that was getting data.
We went to the University of Michigan and
Astra, I had George Fulton, who was, uh,
a wizard and an expert in
a, uh, economic forecasting.
And he had a metrics of
measuring a job impact by, uh,
uh, uh, incentive packages
and, and uh, and that,
and, um, George and his team, uh, uh,
were credible beyond if we had gone
to Michigan state and got that data.
People say, well, it's a homer
kind of a deal. You know,
they're just covering themselves. But by
going to George Fulton and, and his, uh,
national reputation,
and he documented that this plant,
this hundred year old plant was
generating 2% of the wealth in Michigan.
2% of our GM gross domestic product was
coming on to that 100 year old plant.
And that if we could replace the plan,
we would have this much impact.
And if we got to, we'd get this. And,
and we took that data then and began
to educate the community about how
important it was a general motors stay.
And then we developed a strategy to
educate General Motors, uh, about, uh,
the asset at that Labor represented
and that the community, um,
brought in our DNA because we are
a collaborative, uh, group and,
uh, and it slows us down as we knew
it was going to take time. This was,
this plays out over about
a seven year period. Uh,
the Blue Ribbon Committee that we had
actually functioned a as a formal group
for five or six years. Um, but, um,
to answer your question, you,
you just modeled ahead. I mean,
we didn't have a great detailed plan,
but I had been a legislator for 20 years.
Probably the best training I had for the
task was teaching high school dropout.
Try when I was a high school government
teacher prepared me well for working in
the legislature. Uh, but it also
prepared me well for working in,
in this kind of environment. Uh, because,
uh, when I was in the legislature,
I was a chairman of the welfare budget.
So every year I took a beating and trying
to get this budget passed and you're
always putting together coalitions.
You're always trying to get the budget
passed and this is the most political
budget. Uh, so, um, I
chaired that for 16 years.
He had the experience of
bringing people who don't like each
other together and getting the focus on a
common goal. So that's what we
did. It took time. Uh, but uh,
it paid off in spades.
I have one more question before I
will physically here
rather than, um, you know,
we'll go through the process of the book
when can see open challenge and he came
up.
But here we have the living,
breathing your body and then just
living and doing that day in, day out.
So you're wasting your time.
You have a self,
the challenge and the other one gets
thrown up for all of you personally,
you know,
how did you continue to dig deep and
find that passion to continue to problem
solve? And that's something we, we
like to think we do at Google everyday.
But you have a really big worlds example
of having done it an impact and so
positively the lives of so many people.
So it's nice to hear your
personal experiences of how
you dig deep and how you
force yourself to do it. Right.
Okay. I think my formal
training was as an engineer.
I got my masters,
a bachelors and Masters at Michigan State.
I was a civil engineer. Civil engineers
build roads, they build buildings,
they get involved in all
kinds of different projects.
So this was totally out
of character for me.
I had never taken on a project like this,
but the training that I had received
during the course of my career and the
course of my college
education was problem solving.
Engineers have to be problem solvers.
Uh,
you folks are problem solvers
and that's what that's about.
It's like you have to rely on all of your
experience and the folks that you have
around you and the ability to dig deep.
It's dig deep. I learned that
there was a, an equation for this.
It's called five whys.
Why do you do this and why do you do that?
And we'll dig down,
drill down and keep drilling down
and eventually you get to a solution.
And that's what we did.
That's why I with the Terry
because I think Terry,
I'm message makers all they do as being
innovative and creative. So great.
I mean it's sort of part of his business
part I think. And give me a good story.
Nope. Our task here was to help tell this
story and really what I wanted to say.
I said, you know, you
have a few people here,
but I was not involved
in the team that kept GM.
I lived in the community,
but our task was to retell that story
and Dave and ray came to me and said,
you know that people are moving, passing
on whatever and we got to capture it. Uh,
so we interviewed what 40,
50 people they are in the documentary
there in the book and you get this,
get that perspective on it and
not just ours but theirs as well.
And it's pretty fascinating. And,
and I encourage you to look at it.
Oh, it was important to me
if not winning or losing.
The important thing is the integrity
you bring to the process and being
transparent, being inclusive,
uh, being focused on when, when,
uh, those were important that you
do, you're going to have setbacks,
you're going to get, you're going
to have failures. So, you know,
I couldn't undaunting task,
but uh,
and I had joined motors telling me not
to do it, not to do, do it publicly.
Uh,
but if you create a process
that is transparent and
participatory and inclusive
and focused on win win, then then
you can take those setbacks, uh,
so that winning and
losing and not the issue,
the issue is the integrity of the process
and the integrity you bring to the
process.
We as a book author, team method,
pretty much weekly for ever.
It seems like to put this into code of I
for one and a transparency and trust or
two words that these two guys brought
up every single freaking week.
That had to be the mantra for
the storytelling. Not Trust
between us. That's fine.
But transparency with the community in
the late 90 nineties telling them sort of
what the, what they needed to know.
Perhaps not every single detail, but uh,
the trust had to be built with the
community and all these parties
as a by training is,
is basically in supply chain and I'm a
Michigan Native and spent the last 20 or
40 years of my life in Lansing.
So I had a really passion for,
for the whole thing.
And I think what really got me interested
in this is people were talking about,
well Michigan is not relevant because our
labor costs are too high or what other
excuses we had in terms of that and the
fact understanding supply chain and the
fact there are a lot of trade offs.
And in this particular case,
one of the key trade offs as
talent and labor and, and uh,
getting people to understand that that
is not a trance transferable thing.
You can just can't pick it up
and move it someplace else.
One of the stories that came out of the
book is a lot of the Lansing workforce,
our old farm boys.
And I'm not saying that negatively,
I'm saying it was one point of view.
These are the people
that make stuff work and,
and that's one of the differentiators
in the plant that they keep the plant
working because they,
they are,
they have that hands on attitude
and telling that story was,
was so very important to me.
Okay.
Beautiful. I'll take it back
then. Okay. I have a loud voice.
That's what I was saying that, so, um,
you mentioned, uh, there was 40 other um,
plants or we're looking to shut down.
Did you find any other communities or
cities catch wind of what you are doing
and you were public about it?
Did they come to you guys to try and
mimic what you were trying to do and was
anyone else successful?
Okay.
In some interesting way,
obviously.
And I'm speaking for the two academics
a little bit because we'd been questing
and part of the process is that
we quest in these guys too.
So every chapter has a reflections by
ray Todd got shot in the reflections by
the mayor so that they get to tell
their story in an I personality, uh,
wording, if you will. Uh,
but part of it was that General Motors
knew what everything that was going on,
but they wanted to sign on
to an absolutely nothing
because in some way, uh,
implicitly I think speaking on professor
close on myself as behalf myself behalf,
I think they were supportive but there
were never going to sign onto it.
So that question that you're
asking if other communities,
what I've gotten wind of it and General
Motors had been even a little bit
supportive.
They want to use large loads,
the same blueprint when 40 out
of plants were being shut down.
And not that that became
a competitive thing,
but they were not going to say that this
is the perfect model to keep us do this
in the future. And I think get
mayor Hollister throughout the work,
through the aspect of it as well.
[inaudible] president I macpherson of
Michigan State University took this model
that we had developed and he as
he organized Michigan State's, uh,
a strategy of attracting the
facility for rare isotope beams.
This was a federal initiative,
was a department of Energy
Program of $800 million.
The competitor was a in Chicago and
was in the district cove out, uh,
President Obama. So we were taking
on debt to win this competition,
uh, an uphill battle. And, uh, he,
he brought together a statewide
group of influential people. He, uh,
I bought two macro Tom Board. We played
to our strengths, we engaged students,
uh,
and he was successful in bringing
this rare isotope facility to Msu.
That was a model that it was directly
a pattern after what we did on a much
larger scale.
Other communities can adopt this,
but we haven't seen many
a most documentaries. Uh,
ray and I looked at some
documentaries are a,
the closing and the kind of looking
back what went wrong and you know,
Janesville Wisconsin was one read
recently was on public television.
We wanted to tell a story that
celebrated the fact that we, we,
we won the battle,
uh,
but also to document it and
kind of memorialize it and, and,
and more importantly to educate
the millennials. Uh, what, uh,
what, what's the, what's the foundation
upon which our current economy is built?
Lansing is now much more diverse
in its economy. It has a,
a vibrant it sector,
350 it firms.
It's second only to Hartford, Connecticut
and insurance and finance headquarters.
Uh, it is, uh,
a high tech companies that are spinning
out of the cyclotron and the rare
isotope, uh, beam, uh, effort. Uh,
so we wanted these young people,
uh,
like you're a employee employment base
to recognize that while the automobile
industry represents the old economy,
they also have been part of the transition
to the new economy. And, and Lansing,
we didn't know it at the time.
We were struggling with how to transform
from the old basic manufacturing with
unskilled labor to the new economy
with advanced manufacturing and highly
skilled labor. In fact, one of the
reasons we got the, uh, the f f Rib,
the facility for a rare isotope beams
is the highly skilled workforce that the
UAW had that could take a building that
they're building and design it and then
modify it as it goes through the
process because it's a seven,
eight year process of building the
building and you've got skilled enough
workers that can make the adjustments and,
and,
and a modified the building as the
science unfolds because it's the same
dynamic. Uh, so that's kind of
a long answer to your question.
One of the things that when
we started this process,
we had no idea where we're going to go
or what we're going to do solving on the,
on the run, so to speak, is there was
no manual out there that said, you know,
go to page 27, you'll find out
how to do this or that. Uh,
so we had to create this as we went,
but the success of what we did,
now we've had communities call us and say,
we'd like to kind of emulate your model.
Can we do it over the phone?
No, you really can't. You know.
So Dave was asked to go to Janesville
and I was asked to go to Janesville,
but they didn't want,
you know, much promise.
They thought we can
handle it over the phone.
So they tried a little bit of the model.
They didn't use the whole model
and as a consequence they failed.
But they've reinvented. I mean I'm
happy for them because they'd become a,
a central area for medical now,
uh,
there between Milwaukee
and Chicago. So they, uh,
have attracted a significant
business area there. At any rate,
other communities have tried to do
something similar, but most have failed.
Now that we've put the model in
writing and thanks to David and Thomas,
we were able to do that in a way that
would make sense to other communities and
make sense to students as they read this.
Uh,
so we're grateful for the opportunity.
The last thing I want to add is that
this effort ended up being a $3 billion
plus investment in the Lansing
region since we started this process.
That doesn't include all the suppliers.
So there is a huge,
huge amount of investment here and to
saving over 70,000 jobs in the state of
Michigan.
Thank you.
You're in front of you today and that
will hear your story and online and
congratulations on contribution.
Thank you.